so politics is actually solving the
problem of religion with a
with something that actually makes the
problem worse uh at least politics when
adopted in this fashion
it's not necessarily intrinsically
uh a a religion
replacement it's more of a community
replacement
um but in any event it definitely makes
the problem worse
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissinger
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people now as you know we spend a lot of
time
talking about the culture war and today
we have someone who can actually take us
a level above that and look at some of
the bigger processes
that are happening under all of that
jordan hall welcome to trigonometry
yeah thanks i'm interested to find out
what the conversation unfolds
uh well we will we will find out but
listen i i was saying to you before we
started
we recently interviewed david fuller
from rebel wisdom that's how we came
across your stuff and i just thought
you have such a much broader conceptual
frame
to discuss many of the things that are
happening in society
uh things that we've talked about on the
show whether that's the cultural whether
that's
the changes that are happening in the
media landscape the
the politics of the last four years
which which you've all
are all things that you've talked about
as i say from a much broader perspective
you've talked about
how the changes that have occurred in
the last you know century let's say
uh in terms of technological progress in
terms of the explosion and the
population
in terms of the the breakdown of what
you call uh the blue church
in particular the sort of down from
authority communication to a group of
people
in terms of mass communication all that
sort of stuff
so the question i want to start by
asking you is
what the hell is going on in the world
and why is it happening
hmm oh okay well there's
let me see maybe do this in multiple
different levels so the first point
lots of things that's against maybe the
first insight is that if you try to
reduce it down to any small number of
things you're definitely doing at a
disservice
likely confusing yourself or potentially
lying to other people
so lots of things are going on in the
world and they're happening in different
levels
like some things are happening at i
don't know how we say it uh
at uh at a scale a spatial scale and a
temporal scale that we might call
um now like
in the in the year right there are
things that are happening that were
happening in in terms of how people make
choices
how institutions execute cycles like
that just think about
some sort of phenomenon like uh like you
know that that really cool
new musical device where you can record
and loop yeah and then you can loop you
know play music with yourself
i've got one loop that's going on i
don't know maybe a year loop
and so it has this time sequence in
terms of how it does what it does
and then i've got other loops that are
moving at different temporal loops
different spatial loops and they have
different
propagations through the environment
that we're in so for example
one thing that's going on is homo sapien
sapiens is not yet ever really fully
dealt with the fact that we're a
technological species
that's been going on a long time right
and that has profound implications that
continue to ramify and cascade to the
entire
sociocultural field and we're kind of
dealing with these
giant ripple effects have been bouncing
off the edges
of our world for a long time
and that's coming home to roost in big
ways and it has continuously done so
over a long period of time
at a lower level of sort of scale has to
do with the fact that we happen to be
right at the cutting edge of one of the
major waves
in that bigger story you know many
there's many different names of it and
by the way that
that wave isn't one wave it's like a
dozen
or 50 waves that all happen to be
linking up together so
you know it becomes a much bigger
phenomenon
another piece of it is that the
implications of that kind of a change
we we tend and particularly we modern
post-enlightenment scientific
physicalist rationalists
tend to focus on change happening
outside
as a technical economic physical
material like climate change
is salient we get it those are changes
that happen out there
but of course the same quantity
magnitude
and quality kind of changes
are also going on in our and our
interior we are produced by the
environment as much as we produce the
environment
and so but because we're not
simultaneously not particularly prepared
to be aware of and respond to those
changes and because those changes are
actually of the same level of magnitude
as the ones that are going on in the
exterior
that's another big upwelling that's
causing all kinds of confusion and
disruption
right so we've got multiple different
stories multiple different ways
moving in different paces and and
complexly
interacting with each other and so it
creates a highly
chaotic environment um
and in that context i guess maybe the
last piece
because it refers to some of the stuff
we're talking about earlier
for the most part to the degree to which
we are endeavoring
even consciously like actually
intentionally endeavoring to respond
to the problem the the methods by which
we go about
making sense of what's happening and
making choices about how to respond are
themselves part of the problem
and the mental image i have is like if
you've got a
you're driving a car and something goes
wrong with the steering columns there's
a lag
so when you turn left it actually takes
longer than you're used to
and this car starts waggling out of
control but in order to get the car to
go straight you keep turning even more
abruptly
you're actually adding to the problem
that's another piece of the story
so obviously i just threw a big chunk
out there but there you go
that sounds familiar uh by the way just
a reminder we're too comedian so don't
don't get too clever on us uh but uh
in terms of the the the responses to
what's happening we'll get to that
perhaps
can we just get to to the what's
happening what is this lag
in the turning that's happening uh in
particular you know the issue that i
found very interesting is your
description of um how the media
landscape has changed as a result of the
emergence of the internet and other
types of technology
uh can you just break that down for our
for us and our viewers and listeners
sure sure and then let me maybe propose
to also talk about um
the institutional framework let's do
both of those yeah
place and do them at the same time um
okay so we have a
what's right way of putting it we have a
way of doing things
individually but in this case in
particular at a level of of
how our social technologies um
come together actually i'm going to put
it this way
i'm going to walk us up i'm going to
create a framework and then use that
framework
so when television first came
uh into the into the uh showed up this
is
television happens the people who are
creating television programming
don't really know what it is they're
dealing with obviously right it's new
and so they do their best to to to do tv
which for the most part means they point
a camera
at what effectively is a form of
broadway play
they take something they know and
understand and they add this
new ingredient to it thus begins though
an actual experiment an actual
learning of the nature of the underlying
new thing that has a bunch of different
characteristics
for example uh unlike a broadway play in
television you can have two cameras
you can cut back and forth and force the
viewer to actually shift that
perspective right you actually can
control the territory the viewer's
attention is focused on in a way
in a play you cannot and of course you
can do that not just in terms of
a visual perspective you can do it in
terms of time i can do i can cut back
and forth in time very easily
et cetera et cetera there's all kinds of
things that happen as we begin to
explore
the actual characteristics of the novel
milieu of
television by the way the same thing is
actually happening on the part of the
audience
the audience that's watching early early
tv hasn't yet
understood what it is they're watching
so they're experiencing something but
as the audience becomes more and more
sophisticated they begin to build a
storehouse of say for example what tv
tropes are and it becomes a new
vocabulary a new vernacular so when a
certain scent
context begins to show up like you hear
the the chords of music that is playing
in the background in your body i was
like oh
now i'm supposed to feel that it's
dramatic for example
this is actually a really interesting
co-developmental process of
understanding what the potentials of the
medium are
and the relationship between creative
expression and perception
in that context that builds more and
more capacity to actually
move into this new place okay so that's
that's a framework so we enter into a
new media landscape
naively and usually by treating as if
it's the old one
then we learned how to build
competencies and capacities
as both perceiver and ex and receiver in
that new media landscape and then we're
sort of operating in that fashion then a
new one comes along
okay so this is true also in a broader
context
if i'm looking at for example how um
how governance works one of the
challenges
of governance in in the 20th century
actually for a very long period of time
but in the 20th century in particular
is that you're dealing with very large
populations more or less
generally over large geographic regions
often times with
meaningful diversity and heterogeneity
of cultural
assumptions and yet we need to find some
way to get them all to more or less
agree
on a relatively narrow set of choices
and so we have two things going on
simultaneously that tend by the way to
uh reinforce each other as television
for example emerged in the mid-century
governance began to learn how it can use
television to do the thing that it needs
to do which is ultimately to create a
what's called a cybernetic control
structure i don't mean that necessarily
as a negative
you know the previous example the
steering wheel is a form of cybernetic
control structure it's how i can use my
uh intelligence and agency to
uh to control to to steer
some kind of underlying system right so
even the concepts of by the way
cybernetics happen to emerge in that
time frame so it's
a little bit of self-referentiality
there um
and so by the time you get to the 90s
and at least in the united states i
don't actually know what the specifics
are
in your place we get to a place where
governance had become quite tv native
meaning both the tools and techniques
the approaches
the understandings the habits the
unconscious instincts
and also the possibilities and
capacities of what actually could be
effectively managed and steered through
this particular modality
and an audience that had been prepared
for example i remember very clearly
as a 8 or 10 year old my dad would turn
on the nightly news every night
local news why it was his civic duty he
had been
trained to watch the local news every
night as part of a civic duty which is
to say he plugged into the cybernetic
control structure mediated through
television
and it was important and useful right he
was connected to that system
and then the system had learned how to
do things like how do you create the
right kind of messages
how do you shape the into the overturned
window is yeah
how do you shape the overton window so
that it's broad enough
that people feel like they're getting a
a real consideration what's happening
but also narrow enough that actually
causing choices to happen within the
bandwidth that we have as choice makers
is also feasible like that kind of stuff
but of course as we enter into the 90s
we also enter into the emergence of an
entirely new media landscape
this new digital media this interactive
digital
highly decentralized or distributed
landscape comes online
which has completely different
characteristics
than broadcast television you know
instead of being
for example in in america three channels
it is in fact an infinite number of
channels and instead of having the
characteristic
of temporal flow with no memory
like you know right right when i'm
watching the nightly news
up until the invention of like tivo it
was just gone right the second it the
moment had passed that moment was in the
past
and so memory was very much not part of
the story uh
what was it part of the story was what
gets my attention now
and what leaves a felt sense of of
making good good choices okay it feels
like we're doing okay that's it that's
the only memory i've got we can kind of
vaguely refer to things that happened to
the past but
hard to know exactly obviously in the
digital environment the internet never
forgets
you know to the degree to which you guys
choose to broadcast this video it will
then be a durable trace that 10 000
years from now
assuming somebody has the capacity to
to sort of do digital technology it'll
still be there it can be rewound and
looked at second by second
um and of course highly decentralized
meaning that you guys didn't have to ask
anybody's meaningful permission to begin
the process of actually creating a new
form of communications channel
and neither did i you know i can go on
youtube now of course
the evolution of the control structures
in the context of the new
media channel is already happening a
pace so the the development and
discovery of different techniques of
trying to control
how do you engage in the kinds of
shaping of conversation that are valid
and meaningful
and effective in this new meal you is is
happening right it's accelerating
actually
but from the period of of 2000 and so
and particularly 2008 2009 2010
this just has to do with relative rates
of penetration of the amount of tension
that was applied to the different media
and the ages of different generations
whose psychologies and underlying habits
have been developed in different
environments
um began to create a sort of a mixture
of underlying forces is kind of like
when a river flows into the ocean
you've got kind of cool fresh water
mixing with whatever the temperature the
ocean happens to be let's go with warm
salt water
it creates a very turbulent environment
in the middle
and that's large that's a big been a big
piece of what's actually happening is
that
which is a deeper thing now we see lots
of stuff
happening at a more superficial level
which doesn't mean by the way that it's
not relevant it just means that it's
happening
at a different level of causation and
scale
but in many cases a deeper cause is what
i was just describing
we can by the way there's an arbitrary
we could go weeks on just that
and pulling pieces of that out if we'd
like
and what is the effect of this on our
society
this new media this new way of
communicating the fact that anybody can
have
access to an audience anybody can have
access to disseminate the information
that they believe is valuable
and frame it in their own way
well okay there's there's two different
categories of response to that one has
to do
with an exploration of the underlying
characteristics of the medium which i'd
actually like to get to
later in a moment and the other has to
do with with the specifics of what i was
just describing which is to have to do
this the change so the change has one
impact on our society the change in and
of itself
the second has to do with the the the
shift the journey to this new location
um so the change shows up as
uh things like surprise confusion
anxiety conflict in ways that don't
necessarily make sense because part of
what's happening
is pre-existing categories are finding
themselves no longer
applicable to the new environment you
can imagine that i've got a
like a company like the new york times
right the new york times
has a has a sense of being the new york
times so it has almost a verticality to
it almost like it's like a box there's a
new york times there's a culture of
people who are part of it
but the emergent wholeness of the new
york times
has latent cross cuts of various kinds
of
of mimetic tribes
that are in it and because this new
environment
has a different pull almost like a
shearing strength there's
tension and pulling on the wholeness of
the interior of the
of the new york times which is is in
many ways confusing particularly to
older people like the old that creates a
there's a big generation gap the the
more tv
your mind is for example again there's
lots and lots of things going on but
the more tv your mind is the more odd
and weird and strange it is that these
kinds of things that are coming
up from this new digital decentralized
capacity to show up in the way they show
up
things like pace and style that are very
not of the same sort
so disruption surprising disruption
generalized anxiety because of the
presence of simple novelty and the
breakdown of old forms and habits that
seem to make sense
but no obvious way of understanding or
being able to
feel comfortable with what's happening
probably a little bit like the way that
animals feel before an earthquake
like something big and momentous is
happening but i don't know what the hell
it is
and so it's like almost in the body a
basic felt sense of
flea or undifferentiated energy that
bran in some sense almost randomly shows
itself up people are scrambling
to find out what's a safe and or good
place to be
in a context where they really don't
know what's happening
okay now the other side of the equation
the the other piece which has to do with
the
the the underlying nature of the new
mill u um
[Music]
well maybe two points one point is we
don't know so
as part of what's happening is we
actually are entering into a new
period of deep uncertainty and a new
period of exploration and journeying and
learning how to become capable of that
like
unlearning the habits of being
cogs in a well-functioning machine and
relearning the capacity of being
explorers or journeyers or humans in a
new niche
and that's actually depending on the
magnitude of change there's almost like
a verticality how far down that
unlearning and relearning do we have to
go
but if we look at the at the
characteristics of this new environment
there are a few
like almost like islands that pop out of
the ocean
high points that you can kind of point
at right now from where we are
and frankly they look a lot like what's
going on in china uh the social credit
score
the uh uh the and by the way a french
philosopher named
pointed this out in the mid 90s he
called it the societies of control and
this has to do with the fact that
in a in a a digital environment
the ability to perceive and signal
and then modulate signal at a very very
fine grain and at a very very rapid and
bespoke pace
so for example in the context of
broadcast television
the message had to be a message that was
sort of generically targeted to a large
demographic
even the contact concept of demographics
was invented
by marketers to make sense of how to use
tv effectively
in the context of digital uh what we're
discovering is that in fact
the appropriate the technology enables
and the appropriate mode
is actually micro targeting on the
interior of your own
your individual human psychology all
right so i don't want to create a
message
targeting say the three of us i don't
don't even want to create a message
targeting
you i want to create these tiny tiny
nudges
clusters of them that are all
qualitatively different that actually
impact your psychological interior
inside your own mechanism of maintaining
the integrity of your own
psychology so as to nudge you in a
fashion that you don't even perceive as
happening
but as you like as as a distinct human
being a distinct agent in the
environment
so micro control and fluid modulation
like instead of having it happen as a
like a
apple is an example of like actually a
pretty strong
tv style or broadcast style
where this this build up that's to spend
a lot of time planning and have one
big significant focused really high
quality event that
hits hard that kind of a move in the
digital environment as you move further
and further and further down you
actually get is something that's much
more like
short fluid iterations that change
rapidly
and it's more like fluid dynamics have
you ever seen that what that looks like
um like if you if you watch the water
flow into a
tidal tidal tide pool where there's lots
of rocks
you can see the complexity of the tide
as it flows in and out
it's like that it's much more like that
um
so fluid modulation and then think about
what happens at the level of the
physical environment
and this is again think china um where
uh let me just do the virtual first and
i can do the concrete a second
and when i show up to amazon.com
i guess you show up to amazon.co.uk
what i see is not what you see and we
see something that has a lot of
aesthetic similarity because amazon
wants to maintain the continuity of its
brand
but by definition it's bespoke right i
see something that is perfectly
optimized to the degree to which amazon
has information and competence
to cause me to buy [ __ ] and it's
different
the kind of stuff that will cause you to
buy [ __ ] yeah now just imagine what
happens in our physical environment
has that same set of characteristics
right where
the pub you literally just can't even go
into the pub
because that pub is not part of your
modulated flow stream
so you you get into the self-driving
electric
replacement for the cab and there's only
a certain number of places that you can
go and there's other places that if you
go there they are vastly cheaper for you
to get into for example just use
economics there's so many different
variations on the theme because
in this new environment the number of
different control mechanisms like
control currencies goes way up
so let me just come and give you an
example you go to
pub number one and one thing that
happens is it's three times as expensive
per drink
and the second thing that happens is
your uh
your your ability to show up as a a good
possible date in
you know the new version of tinder goes
down
all right so if you go to this pub then
it costs you more to drink beer and
you're going to have less sexual
uh success right if you go to sounds
like london jordan
well with pub number two you go into
that pub and it's cheaper
and your tinder score goes up right
well your almost everybody is just going
to flow to pub number two
um well guess what we now have very
bespoke and that's just two currencies
by the way two powerful ones money and
sex
but there's many many more right and the
idea is that in this novel digital
environment the capacity for that exists
how exactly it shows up who knows and by
the way it'll probably show up
differently depending on exactly
how the design what ends up designing or
controlling
the design of that control structure you
know the chinese version will look very
different than say for example the eu
version although not
as far as i can tell radically different
um
so that's an example just to kind of get
a gesture in the direction of the kinds
of things to be looking out for
in terms of principles fluidity micro
um very bespoke and maybe some concrete
examples of how it shows up in amazon
and how it might show up in the
self-driving pub of the future
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for the
newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
jordan so basically at the moment we all
have our
own virtual reality and i'm fully aware
of this like
i know that when i am writing a joke
let's say as a comedian or making a
tweet that i want to make a certain
point
if i'm referencing something there's
quite a large portion
of other people who have no idea what
the hell i'm talking about because
they've got their own twitter
right and what you're talking about is
on a physical level that will start
to take shape to the point where
eventually we're all going to have our
own reality
in every way now yeah
now i mean this may be my inherent
pessimism coming out here and i'm the
optimistic one of the two of us
both chose to be comedians this implies
they're both pessimistic
yeah so that doesn't sound like a recipe
for anything good to me
well when i say if you if you wear
strict colored glasses the things look
like [ __ ] so yes
what i would say is that it has uh three
consequences
uh one consequence is that it will uh
and oftentimes in a very surprising way
cut
existing gordian knots surprisingly
easily
so problems that are wicked problems now
are actually wicked because
our underlying capacity to solve
problems can't address them
but this new mode will have different
ways of directing problems and quite
often will actually end up just
evaporating problems right now feel very
intractable so for example maybe climate
change
turns out to be trivially solved in this
new environment
how some perhaps well if i can imagine
something like
uh if i if i have a a
currency structure do you want me to go
down
i can do it if you'd like if you can do
it in a brief and understandable way
that would be great
well i can't vouch to say for
understandable uh
particularly when and never to do it
briefly it's something like
imagine if we had the capacity and in
fact we kind of do
imagine we had the capacity to identify
every single
uh externality that our current supply
chains threw into the environment
that makes sense yeah imagine if we we
tracked it down to the granular level at
every single transformation across the
supply chain
and then imagine if we if we use that
information
to drive the control structure that was
nudging people's behavior at a very
fine-grained level
for example i'll just use a slightly
different one than climate change let's
just go with
litter all right i don't know if you
guys do people smoke in england
um we i mean yeah some people do some
people do it's very retro jordan well
back when i was younger people smoked a
lot and one of the things i noticed as a
kid is you'd go to the park and sit at a
park bench and they were
cigarette butts everywhere yeah well
imagine if every single cigarette comes
with an
rfid tag attached to it and every single
purchase of cigarettes
actually immediately identifies the
individual human being who last owned it
so that when you throw the cigarette
butt away it shows up on a database as
your cigarette butt that's on the ground
and negatively impacts your social
currency score to the point where nobody
litters anymore
for example right now just generalize
that across all possible externalities
we could sort of
extinguish pollution to the degree to
which we have the competence to actually
track it effectively
so that'll be an example okay um
that makes sense so that's the first
type of so you will be good for that and
also by the way you know when i said it
all be negative
obviously the ability to fulfill human
desires wishes needs etc will be
multiplied manifold because
you're getting a super tailored service
it's not all bad agreed well
this is the point it opens up new
opportunities and creates new problems
that's it
right but but the the reason that i was
saying
there's nothing good i didn't mean that
there's nothing good what i meant was
if you are in an environment where
everybody lives increasingly in their
own reality
the the lack of understanding of other
people
and the potential for tribalism that
comes out of that to me is quite scary
yeah i think if you sort of i don't mean
by any means to poo poo the
the the challenges quite quite the
opposite
um the maybe even a better way of
putting it is
every time we enter into a new enter a
new technology into our environment
we unlock both opportunities and
risks the more powerful the technology
the more powerful the opportunities and
the more powerful the risks
this particular set of technologies is
several orders of magnitude more
powerful than anything we've ever
unlocked before
and therefore the risks are several
orders of magnitude
larger and in this case there are
several orders of magnitude larger
because actually
of the micro nature the nuclear bomb
back in the late in the mid-century was
big dangerous powerful but very macro
and it was a you know only for for most
of the time
only two countries meaningfully had the
the ability to use it at all and still i
think it's only like six or seven
and highly high can constrain one event
nuclear bomb
and that's a concentrated very salient
risk it's kind of easy to focus your
attention on it
this new environment has to do with the
fact that we're doing hundreds of
quadrillions of things
all happening in very very narrow basis
and small
deviations in our design characteristics
of say the underlying machine learning
that drives most of this
may lead to huge shifts in human
psychology and behavior
and we don't even vaguely have the
capacity to predict any of that right
now
so for example that's actually a deeper
version of what you just said
but broadly speaking something like huh
actually it's funny
so uh a radical divergence or radical
heterogeneity
of worlds is simultaneously
the best possible and the worst possible
scenario that we can i can currently
imagine
on the one hand uh creative potential
exists as the connection between
heterogeneous worlds
you and i can actually have meaningful
useful delightful creative experiences
in relationship precisely because we
inhabit different worlds
and to the degree which we are
inhabiting different worlds our ability
to communicate
our ability to actually connect and be
in a relationship at all
the numbers of mistakes and errors and
misunderstandings that we will have
also goes way way up so it becomes
harder and harder to maintain
quality relationships and a large part
of what's happening right now is
precisely that
we're using a toolkit that of of
relationality
i see on twitter that has an underlying
assumption
of shared context when in fact that's
not even vaguely true
so we're running this you know something
that assumes shared context and projects
it on the other
and then what's really happening is the
others actually got a completely
different context by the way not just
deep context but even moment-to-moment
context as you say like i'm reading
five twitter feeds and have a certain
context
you're reading five twitter feeds the
only ones vaguely the same as the one
that we happen to be on right now
and even that is a different context and
of course you put 128 characters into
your tweet
which is a minuscule amount of context
to provide to me and i respond with 128
characters which is a miniscule amount
of context to respond to you
the implication of course being either
we both have to be
quite wise like quite quite mature
and skillful at understanding the nuance
and subtlety of what happens when two
beings from very different worlds with
very little context are in communication
or we're going to make lots of mistakes
and jordan
to me this is it's it's a very worrying
conversation because
how are you able to mitigate the worst
effects of a type of technology
if you don't know what the downsides and
the dangers of this technology are
aren't you just simply stumbling blind
into into
you know a situation which you have no
control over
i would actually go more along the lines
of i don't know uh
snow skiing at a breakneck
speed blind through that environment
with a complete uh and completely
inebriated
something like that the magnitude of the
lift is quite high
yeah but but part of that is say okay
well if that's the metaphor
stop drinking sober the [ __ ] up take off
the skis and
walk down the goddamn mountain right so
what does that look like
what does that look like in this context
ah well this is interesting a big part
of it actually starts with
three things you know it's almost like
you can go to a a
you know first admit you've got a
problem you first actually recognize
that this is the case
you know you have to slow down enough to
actually whoa oh [ __ ] i am
uh speeding down a mountain at breakneck
speed totally inebriated
maybe that's not the best place to
become conscious to restore yourself to
a kind
being a conscious agent in the world
that'd be the first step
and of course most people find
themselves careening about an
unconscious reaction
and an increasing addiction to creating
about an unconscious reaction
so that's not a small step
the next step is to begin the process of
carefully disconnecting yourself from
this from the things in your context to
which you are most addicted
and beginning to to give yourself
permission
to go as slowly as you need to to be
able to actually make effective choices
on a moment-to-moment basis now this is
very challenging
if you have anything vaguely like an
ethical commitment to the well-being of
other people or the world
because you will be slowing down and
disconnecting
while you're watching everything around
you get worse and worse and potentially
catastrophically so
and this is a tricky business to be able
to to choose
to say okay well shoot i can say with
some degree of confidence and clarity
that
the path that we're on is not going to
work and that i can't solve the path
i can't get the car out of its skid by
increasingly jerking back and forth on
the steering wheel the best thing to do
is in fact to
take my foot off the brake take my hand
you know stop steering
and slow down until i notice some new
groove something that shows up where ah
effective choice just happened this is
that going down i don't know if you guys
are all familiar with something called
theory you no no i'm not particularly
familiar with it but it's somewhat known
it has to do with this exactly this
process at the in the interior of the
psychology
so you could say like meditation like
this meditation practice is a practice
of going down to the bottom of the u
disentangling your awareness from
habituated emotional and cognitive
responses until you get to a place where
you actually are
at long last free like actually
disentangled no longer
behold into habits of mind and habits of
emotion
from which you can then go back up the
other side of you and begin to
from a place of conscious choice and
with some degree of some degree of
effectiveness
move back into the world uh one metaphor
that i think is actually quite silent is
a little bit like
from the matrix the movie where
first neo had to choose to take i think
it's the red pill right yeah
unfortunately an awfully overcoated
metaphor now but you get it
um which is to say to acknowledge you've
got a problem
then what he discovers is that his ass
was actually um a
uh a body that doesn't even know how to
walk or basically even move
you know entirely around a virtual
simulator his own agency is
actually effectively nil and he gets
unplugged from that entire structure he
went goes to the bottom of you somewhat
abruptly
in his case he has some help right thank
god um
and he gets put on the table and he gets
plugged back up and he gets the process
of relearning how to do basic things
like move his fingers and blink and walk
and breathe
and of course eventually he gets to the
point where he can walk around and eat
and then he gets plugged back in and
learns kung fu
and so the hope might be something like
that's actually a very powerful metaphor
for where we are right now because the
level of
of of lack of agency the level of
helplessness that a person will feel
if they choose to unplug themselves from
the matrix which
say unplug themselves from the habits
and
cognitive structures and institutional
frameworks of power and influence that
they may or may not actually be in right
now
in order to be able to achieve a level
of clarity and slowness where they can
actually begin to be
full agents live players as my friend
simon berger puts it
is a lot it feels very
scary you feel very vulnerable when you
make that move
you do feel very vulnerable when you
make that move jordan but isn't
another part of the problem is that
these negative behaviors
that a lot of people exhibit on these
technologies social media
they're actually incentivized you're
incentivized to be outrageous you're
incentivized
to present you know opinions without
nuance because that will get
maximum engagement therefore
realistically how can you expect
people to behave in the manner that
you're saying
when the reality is if you behave in a
manner which is
less socially responsible should we say
you're going to get far more reward from
it
well um i've heard a story at least
that somewhere in the order of 2 000
years ago
a whole crew of um you know iron age
uh uh pagans
reached a point where they are capable
of
having a disposition of commitment to a
particular ethos
in spite of the fact that the incentive
structure was rather pointed to say that
to choose to be a christian in the early
christian communities
would end up with you being tortured to
death in public which is substantially
more
than getting a down vote in twitter or
whatever the dopamine equivalent might
be
um so getting rationed getting rations
getting ratio right we're more
specifically getting cancelled
you know if the contemporary equivalent
of being fed to the lions is to be
cancelled
what i would say is that you're a rather
pitiful human if you can't actually
stomach that
and i would point out that up until the
relatively recent era
humans have endeavored have suffered
vastly greater
magnitudes of pain and duress for vastly
lower stakes
so that's more i'll put the burden back
on people to say hey
you know take more responsibility
because i know you can't you can take a
lot more like the
the depth of responsibility you're
actually capable of
is so vastly beyond that which you
currently are taking
for effectively everybody myself very
much included um
the to assume that you know what's
possible even in just yourself
is already a form of uh
would you call it self-betrayal
actually all right so step one is you
recognize you've got a problem
step two is you disconnect and slow down
step three step three is you learn how
to have kung fu
step three is you actually begin the
process of in this the step three is
very interesting because it has
two really powerful characteristics that
i think are quite attractive
one is um you you begin to actually
adapt to the reality that you're
actually living in
so what happens is you go down to that
bottom of you of the u
as you're dropping habits and you're
dropping unconscious reactive responses
what you're actually doing is you're
beginning to build adaptive responses
you're actually becoming capable of
being a
a well-fitted organism for this emergent
ecosystem
so you're actually learning how to
thrive in this new environment you're
making the journey from the old
environment to the new environment but
you're making it
from the point of view of a what a human
is right a human is a niche
uh a valley crossing being right we do
niche transition is our primary
competence
we can move from being a desert people
to being eskimos
in a couple of generations and in a
contemporary environment maybe even
faster than that
so you actually become imprint in
principle you are moving to
the strongest position in the new
environment
so it's actually better for you to do it
even though it has pain in the immediate
term just
the idea of valley crossing makes sense
i'm just assuming we've talked about
this a few times
so one is you're crossing the adaptive
valley and net net
when valley crossing is what's up that's
the best possible choice
so that's the first piece uh the second
piece of this of this
movement is that um
this is a little bit of a shift but
we're bringing in other stuff
bringing stuff like my friend john
viveki's uh the meaning crisis
one of the implications of the
environment that we have been in
is that it has traded authentic meaning
for simulacra of meaning at a very high
rate
and also as that environment that we've
been in is breaking down
we're left simultaneously with neither
the authentic meaning
nor the simulacra of meaning and now we
feel the pain of
how deeply foregone we are more uh
with less ability to avoid it again back
to the addict model
right you're an addict as long as you
are
on the junk your real meaningful life
can break down but you don't quite have
to own up to it because the junk can
simulate the feeling of winning but when
you get off the junk you feel
simultaneously
the loss of the junk and the acute pain
of the destruction of the life that you
actually left behind
okay but as you come up the other side
of the u
you are now in recovery you are now in a
process where you can actually begin to
reconnect with actual meaningfulness
in life as a human and so as you begin
to walk your way
up on the other side of the valley not
only do you achieve a higher level of
actual competence in thriving in this
new environment
you also can achieve higher levels of
actual lived felt meaning in a fashion
that is
durable and strong so this is all very
much sort of good news
on the other side of the journey um so
that's what it looks like in step three
but it's slow and frustrating and you'll
fall down quite a few times
i i completely agree the question i
really want to ask
is do you think that this lack of
meaning
that we have in our society do you think
that's part of the reason why we had a
collective meltdown over covid
because overnight everything shut down
all
our industries everything that we judge
ourselves by
everything that in the western world
gives us meanings we were all
sent back to our rooms metaphorically to
think about what we've done to quote a
comedian
and all of a sudden we realize that our
lives don't have as much meaning
as we once prescribed to them hence this
huge crisis that we now face
yeah that's definitely a big part of it
can i actually hit two different um
go for it pluck two strings right there
because the word meaning has a really
interesting double
meaning right in the sense of means to
an end
how to get [ __ ] done and in the sense of
like this felt sense that i have
the capacity to live my life in a
thriving way
both of those and i would say on the one
hand
the the extraordinary
how is this extraordinarily uniform and
catastrophic bungling
of the management of the coveted crisis
reveals the degree to which we lack
meaning in the sense of competence to
respond to our environment
right so one is a uh oh [ __ ] turns out
we haven't
we actually are terrible our
socio-political
choice making infrastructure is quite
terrible we didn't know it
it wasn't we felt it we knew it but we
didn't have to face up to it until
it really hit us in the face that's one
side of it which has a demoralizing
effect like oh [ __ ]
we actually are not in control of our
own destiny we got nothing that can
possibly save us and in fact every time
we
externalize our agency to one of these
institutions we realize with regret that
it was a bad choice
that's one side of it and the other side
of it is exactly as you say
and we in fact have been profoundly
addicted to a whole structure
of little tiny simulacra that have been
trading in
for real meaningfulness and then many of
those
all at once not all of them got sucked
out
and of course what's interesting is that
for the most part
there was a bifurcation event almost
everybody sought as rapidly as possible
to plug into a new set of addictions
in netflix is a good example if you
found yourself binge watching netflix
what that meant was
you needed another addiction right you
just shifted from heroin to cocaine
[Music]
or maybe the other way around and that's
another sign
so broadly speaking yes
uh jordan it's interesting for me i
plugged into my family
my relationship and also the work we do
here but
uh i was going to ask you about the work
we do here because you're sort of making
me question quite a bit of
of everything in the sense that you know
our show is a political
and cultural discussion show we talk
about the political events we interview
people about as i said the culture war
uh cultural things like that and
at the same time i've had the sense for
a long time that politics ruins
everything
right yeah uh and one of the
the subjects that we've talked about
somewhat neither of us is religious but
neither of us can help but notice the
fact that
the as as we've killed god as a society
that's opened up a vacuum and when you
talk about meaning
i i'd argue religion gave people that
meaning for for a period of time
now it seems to be politics and now not
only is a politics that fills that void
for many people
but also because of that politics is now
becoming a religion
it's becoming religious the people act
about their political views as if
they're articles of faith
and now is does that resonate with you
and what what would you make of that
yeah so what comes up for me is that
what i would say is something like
um god nature family community and
authentic self
something like that are like the uh at
the five fingers of meaning
and we have in fact alienated ourselves
from all of those
uh and rather substantially and the one
at the very end authentic self is the
base route from which all the rest has
to happen
and so that's where the bottom of you
comes it's like okay [ __ ] i am not my
identity for example
i am not my narratives and my stories
i'm also not my trauma there's something
that is more fundamental that is
still there always some might call it
soul if you choose to use that language
and when you get back to that place from
that place you can begin the process of
now entering into
renewed relationship with meaningfulness
across the other
four fingers
then you said okay so then what happens
is ah this is actually this this
this notion of bad satisfiers this is
actually from uh the anthropological
literature max neath uh i'm thirsty
i drink a can of coke terrible idea
but i don't have the right tools
something in my life has given me the
wrong tools
so i keep actually getting in my own way
i actually solve the problem with
something that actually makes the
problem worse
so politics is actually solving the
problem of religion with a
with something that actually makes the
problem worse uh at least politics when
adopted in this fashion
it's not necessarily intrinsically
a a religion replacement
it's more of a community replacement um
but in any event
it definitely makes the problem worse
hey kkk do you like feeling silky and
smooth
like a sexual dolphin never talk to me
again
what if i told you that manscaped have
brought out a new and improved lawnmower
3.0
that allows you to be fresh and trim for
the ladies
down below i've been married 20 years
the last time i was fresh and trimmed
down below
jimmy savile was a respected children's
entertainer i'm going to ignore that the
lawnmower has a cutting-edge ceramic
blade
which reduces the risk of having an
accident where you least want an
accident
my bank account no you idiot you know
los huevos oh right plus it's waterproof
which means you can groom in the shower
and it has an
led light so you can get a really
accurate and precise trim
x to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to manscape.com and you'll get
20
off with free shipping just use our code
which is of course
trigger that's 20 off with free shipping
at
manscape.com and use our code trigger
your whereas well thank you excellent
jordan you were also saying as well and
you were identified i can't remember so
you said
family what were the four things you
identified a god
nature community itself isn't the
problem
that we live in a capitalist society and
we can't monetize any of these
therefore we don't deem them to be
important therefore we don't focus on
them
i would actually say quite the opposite
i would say the problem is that we live
in a capitalist society
and we ruthlessly monetize all of these
as much as we possibly can
i call it the strip mining of the soul
and so for example
you know monetization of of religion
comes in the form of something like
avengers end game
right the mytho poetic layer which is
deeply important for us to actually have
the kind of archetypal connections that
allow us to govern our behavior over
long
time scales and deep events has become a
resource to be strip mined by
increasingly
uh sort of super salient simulations for
example
um the bar the pub you know that the the
salient environment of conviviality is a
simulacrum of real community
unless it actually happens to be
connected to a real community in
many places in the uk it actually is and
has been for thousand years
i'm talking about one in a place that
doesn't have that characteristic right
we
replace community with the simulation of
community
uh school same thing right school in
many cases is a replacement for
family and community so in each of these
cases by necessity by the way i wouldn't
say that capitalism
is the core capitalism is a piece of the
entire environment
the bigger challenges is actually what i
call the uh the technologies of empire
which has to do with the um do you wanna
know what the technologies of empire are
and then we can work backwards from
there yeah yeah uh
so so in relationship with with with
literally the indigenous form of
humanness
right so i have to go all the way back
to indigenous humanity
um and that's a whole capacity so things
like self and family and community and
religion are
are at the their most natural all the
way back
there now as i start moving through
history specifically into the zone of
history i enter into the
to the era where the technologies of
empire begin the process of building a
different way of people being together
one of the technologies of empire is is
narrative
and distinct distinguished narrative
from storytelling
narrative has a characteristic of
formality particularly when it's a
written
narrative right when it's written down
or there's something about the
characteristic of the narrative where
the narrative has a reality
it has a uh an authority that is
strictly greater than the people who are
telling the stories
right that's that's what narrative is
and control over the narrative things
like ideology is a derivative of
narrative
and to the degree to which your religion
has become an ideology
it is an illusion from its its more
natural and healthy form
into an imperial form and of course it's
typically used for the purposes of
maintaining structures of empire
um now by the way i would say democracy
is a variation on empire so
it's important to i'm not being narrowly
focusing on say like the roman empire
i'm talking about
a wide variety of structures almost
everything humans have done outside of
the context of the indigenous mode
money accounting the the enumeration and
the tokenification like the abstraction
of relationality
in this new construct instead of
actually being in a relationship of
actually knowing each other with high
degrees of context
and providing each other what we need
through that medium what money does is
it enables us to
radically scale by virtue of
indifference which means that i can
engage in transactions with strangers
who i don't know at all
and i can use the price function to
mediate that i'm not by the way saying
that either money or ideology are
intrinsically terrible although they may
be i haven't come to
that conclusion but they have particular
characteristics they have implications
the third is law right the third again
is this notion of taking
the lived relationships of real people
within the context of their actual
who they are the developmental
environment and what's actually going on
and endeavoring to reify that into an
abstraction
which can be characterized with a set of
a finite set of statements right illegal
code
napoleon of course famously tried to
enumerate all the way down to the detail
right very detailed code
the uk on the other hand actually stuck
with more of a common law system for
most for the most part
which actually harkens back to an older
deeper form a more indigenous form
um bureaucracy
the notion of formal institutional
structures
and the idea that for example joffrey
king joffrey
has the power and deference of a king
even though literally everybody knows
that he is
the most um disgusting human because
we've actually decided to put our
responsibility and agency into an
abstract formal structure
as opposed to into the real human
relationships right no indigenous
culture would
ever do that that's absurd beyond
comprehension it's only when we move
into this new mode
into this mode of empire where that
becomes possible because we're in fact
dependent upon it you know once you
become addicted to empire
oh [ __ ] like i can't not give joffrey
the kingdom because
the implication of that is the formal
implication of the destruction of the
entire social operating system that
enables this
widespread set of kingdoms to operate at
all
right pulling even a little bit on that
thread could pull away the whole sweater
and that my friends is chaos so as you
move a little bit down the historical
arc
into the constructs that happen under
the technologies of empire
you find yourself in a circumstance
where one you're highly dependent upon
them there is no alternative
and psychologically even begin to become
physically dependent upon them like you
just learn lose the capacity
to navigate reality through any other
modality right you learn how to do
things like
you know school largely as a training
ground
to navigate society as defined by the
particular instantiation of the
technologies of empire that happen to be
the ones that you're developing in for
example
and that's why it exists that's what
it's for is to train you to be able to
pull those levers
and be pushed by those buttons in the
appropriate fashion and sort of become
the right kind of
automaton in that construct
do you guys recall why i ended up going
there i lost the four
you were talking about the tools of
empire initially uh
and prior to that that had to do with
what was the
uh i don't recall exactly but actually i
was going to ask you a question about
this which i find really interesting
anyway
you're tied in with some of uh you all
know harare stuff there in terms of the
the
are you familiar with his work no i know
that he exists and i know that people
seem to think it's good i have never
actually read it
uh well one of the things he talks about
is the way that human beings broke out
from the indigenous state
in which you could only live with about
150 other people in a small tribe
and one of the reasons homo sapiens
defeated all forms of other humanoids
uh or humanists whatever whatever where
you pronounce it
hominids yeah in in the battle of of
evolutionary success
was not that they were bigger stronger
or even necessarily more intelligent
necessarily but rather that they were
able to create shared myths that allowed
them to band together and bands
that were bigger than 150 people and
what you were talking about is
essentially
all the stuff we've had to do to be able
to live in a society beyond our small
tribe
has consequences that we are now paying
for right yes that's what you're really
saying
yeah so what the hell did we do jordan
well well now we're sort of in the point
where oh
i think this was actually branched from
the point of view of something like
politics
yes exactly the replacement of religion
with politics
right and the point being something like
uh it's not really capitalism capitalism
happens to be a subset of of
a contemporary piece of the story of
empire
and the story of empires is of the big
story
and you know we've endeavored to escape
from or to reinvent or quite often just
you know the whole [ __ ] thing
collapses and we just reboot it
um but the point is something like
consciously
so now being aware of this proposition
endeavoring to consciously design
a new basis that is not premised on the
axiomatics of empire
that would be what we have to do
and again this is this is a re retelling
of that story that i said which is that
many of the most wicked problems the
problems that are even even mythopoetic
in nature like
cain and abel like deep deep problems um
that we've never historically been able
to truly resolve
uh by hypothesis will in fact find
themselves
in somewhat surprisingly effortlessly
resolved
to the degree to which we are successful
in this kind of a migration a transition
to a post-imperial
modality of humanity
and whole new opportunities and whole
new problems will show up as well
but just to kind of put the hype the the
hypothetical
we know or at least we have a high
degree of confidence that we made that
first move
and we moved from the indigenous mode to
the imperial mode
which means that magnitude is possible
we can do that kind of thing
right so we now sit at a threshold where
the proposition is well we need to do
something like that as well we know we
can well we know we can move in one
direction can we move on the other
that's really the question
well uh moving into the other i don't
think is actually valid
um and i might be wrong and it's
actually one of my
the people i'm beginning to collaborate
with is a tyson yonkoporta down in
australia
who speaks quite eloquently from an
indigenous australian perspective
cross product with a very sophisticated
complex system science perspective right
so it's a very
powerful voice and if i think about the
implications of the transition we're
going under in the more dystopic
version if i take a more pessimistic
view the only guys left standing are his
guys
in the aborigines in australia everybody
else is dead
if i think about what happens if we
actually go down the path
of technologies of this order of power
right the power that we're talking about
orders of magnitude more powerful than
anything we've developed before
without an adequate level of wisdom to
actually govern our choices
not skiing willy-nilly drunk down the
mountain but actually if we don't figure
out how to solve that problem
the end result is not like we die an
unhappy life
right the end result is not that we have
a slightly less pleasant
um we have weeds in the yard right the
end result is we end up killing almost
everybody through a wide variety of
terrible means
many of which we haven't even invented
yet remember bef
in 1939 just look at the technology as
death destruction and power in 1939
compare that to 1946
how far humans could actually go in in
weapons of destruction when [ __ ] got
very very real
yeah imagine if [ __ ] got very very real
on a truly global basis
with eight billion people right all
struggling to be the ones who make it
through
this tiny little possibility of of of
success survival or even just domination
who doesn't want to be on the wrong side
of technologies of tyranny and
domination of this level of control
that's a struggle that might cause
people to up the ante and as soon as you
get into
an arms of that magnitude we have no
idea what's on the other side of that
so likely in that context the only
people who are left standing are in fact
the australian aborigines
so perhaps he has the least amount of
concern he might be like yeah [ __ ] you
guys
we didn't want you to mess with us
anyway and we're going to be fine
so the other side of it is actually
something like we actually have from my
point of view
we have to actually innovate something
that is novel it's not a going back
it's maybe recovering a lot of
remembering and in many ways a going
back
for the purposes of going to the next
place that the going back is the right
foundation from which to go to the next
place but the opportunity and the
possibility
at least for those who want to not end
up just leaving the world to the
australian aborigines and maybe some
you know cool kinds of cybernetic
mutants
um is to figure out how to get to the
next thing
now there's a group in england actually
i call it i think they called rethink
x um who
speak about this in a very different way
than i do and i only discovered their
stuff about a year ago which is neat
because it's quite convergent now i
suspect that we actually converge on
what i just said
we may not um but we converge on a lot
of stuff and one of their points is that
even something as simple and prosaic as
the notion of the fourth industrial
revolution
if you think about the the
the last three in particular the first
two
and their implications for how society
operated
what identity looked like how human
beings moved things like the might
the massive migration of the economy
from like a 90
agricultural rural to a in many modern
worlds 90
urban and technical for example over a
relatively brief period of time
if you think about the fourth industrial
revolution and you propose that it
actually has an order to
magnitude more implication more power
and that's just another way of saying
what i just said
that we're just going through a shift
we're going through a move
we can't in some sense can't help it
we've already lit the
lift the engine like it's it's going
we're writing it the question is how do
we choose to find a way to steer it
or we find ourselves flowing willy-nilly
by wherever it happens to take us
um and you know we can double deep dive
on that i would recommend if anybody's
interested just find their uh
i think it's called rethink humanity and
they talk about it in terms of humanity
one humanity two and humanity three
so my indigenous mode maps to humanity
one and my imperial mode maps to
humanity two
and the hypothetic hypothesis is this
thing they call humanity three
right so they're speaking about that
same you know okay we've got three big
you know two big moves
uh epochal in nature and we're now
entering into what is actually a new
epoch
so the way you navigate that first is
you acknowledge that's what's up
you stop [ __ ] around with things that
couldn't possibly matter
it's a little bit like you're sitting
there on the dock
and i think it's dover i don't really
know sorry what's what's like
where did the titanic take off from uh
it went from belfast originally
oh okay yeah it was built in belfast the
irish like to keep it quiet
all right so you're sitting in belfast
getting ready to get in the titanic
and for whatever reason you happen to
actually know with a high degree of
confidence that is going to be uh
exactly that trip but you're choosing to
actually dick around with the uh
the cocktail napkins on your on your
table
that's that's from my point of view when
i look at the notion of what's going on
in terms of politics right now
that's the frame that i see hey guys
guess what
this ship is going to crash and almost
everybody's going to die quite horribly
all we have to really do is not do that
like
just not run into the iceberg can we
maybe steer a little bit different
or maybe not leave there's all kinds of
possibilities not quite sure what it is
but what really has to happen is enough
people on the ship have to
stop being focusing on the trivialities
that they've been trained to focus on
by 19th century society and by the way
humans developing in the context of 19th
century society
and and just maybe look collectively at
the possibility that there's an iceberg
out there
something like that
well the hardest part yeah i see that
the i guess the the reason people
well i agree with you uh first of all
people are addicted to politics second
it's entertainment
third it whatever but equally
since to a large degree what we do with
the ship
depends on the decisions made by
politicians at least
that that's the argument uh then
[Laughter]
i've got myself haven't i i've got
myself haven't i i could see that the
flaw in my own argument as i was
making it um okay so so what what should
we focus on
yeah let's let's like like this is
another simple example uh there's like
this great memes that have these images
but
but simultaneously imagining that you
are dependent upon the choices of a
bunch of buffoons
and or that you can rely on a bunch of
buffoons to steer your life effectively
is a rather foolish place to be
now acknowledge for reasons of history
these particular buffoons have been
handed the crown of joffrey
all right well that's a real problem i'm
not saying that that's not the case we
can't
naively or stupidly i don't know what
are these antifa now climbing on walls
and painting on bricks
that is a naive and stupid recognition
of the actual underlying reality
they are correct in their assessment
that endeavoring to either be governed
by
or um well to be governed by buffoons is
not going to work
unfortunately they are still reactively
engaging in poor strategies and tactics
right the right response is to actually
slow down like it's the same story all
the time
acknowledge recognize okay [ __ ] biden's
not going to save us
or whoever happens to be in charge of
the uk right now um
well he's definitely not annoying yeah
he's definitely not going to save you no
no boris is anything
yeah no well let's not go there yeah
boris is not going to save you right
abortion
no i think that's fair to say and you
know
again there are things that have
happened in history that we know
right their possibilities are real
they're real possibilities to do things
it is not the case that we must only
vote between trump and biden that's not
the reality of the circumstance that we
find ourselves in
it's a form of addiction it's a it's a
form of learned helplessness motivated
by
a deeper anxiety around taking that
level of responsibility and being
overwhelmed with it preemptively
right does that make sense what i just
said yeah yep right
if you if you really can't deal with
something out that's 10 steps down the
road
but you try all at once to imagine
dealing with it
you'll have a stack overflow and you'll
become demoralized preemptively and then
you won't take the first step
you've got to identify what is a first
step that is a right step it's a step
that is actually a healthy effective
step in the right direction that you can
take
and then you have to take it all right
that's
in some sense simply put not trivial
and just being able to orient and
discern the distinction between
what is a random move and what is at
least a vaguely move
a vaguely positive move in the right
direction but also the courage to take
that step is usually not small
it's going to be a pretty big one and
then you got to figure out from that
new place which is going to be a very
different perspective because now you've
changed
something about you has changed in the
movement of this step it's mostly
an individual transformation is a big
piece of it then what's the next step
and then the next step and then the next
step and then the hope and by the way
pure hope right it's not that we are
dependent upon the captain of the ship
at the end of the day we're dependent
upon everybody on the ship
if enough people on the ship say hey
guys
we need to start dealing with the ship
differently then the captain
and whatever the crew will ultimately
say okay
i get it even if it turns out we have to
grab them and like
you know convince them that they are no
longer actually in charge of the ship
this is the weird thing
this goes back to that notion of learned
helplessness learn formality
at the end of the day it isn't the way
that it is now okay next you know
we can make lots of cool little tactical
moves yeah but they have the guns
all right fair enough but they aren't
even real like boris doesn't have any
guns if he does he's not very dangerous
he ostensibly can command people who
have guns but those people are people
and they're also by the way many many
people it's not like it's like like the
army is a
is a thing like the army is a bunch of
people so
it's like this is it's it's a very
malleable
consciousness raising but i'm conscious
just raising consciousness presencing
you know moving from being an
unconscious automaton merely habitually
reacting in some trained and
amygdala hijacked way to having a
conscious
responsibility for the choices that
you're making and then the process of
progressively becoming more capable in
yourself and more
and more with other people to have
broader strategic competence
i actually call this sovereignty three
or sovereignty you know sovereignty two
was this notion of it's not
the god-king it's these nation-states
sovereignty three is not something that
is invoked upon you by virtue of being
it's actually something you build it's a
it's actual competence the ability to
actually take responsibility for more
and more effective choices
in more and more contexts and
that's it like we're on a journey of
that shift but let's go back let's be
very like let's be hopeful
um there's a breakdown right the old
modes of power are very obsolete they're
big
they control everything right now but
they're also degrading rapidly
they're rather stupid and they don't
have any real clue to how to use the new
modes of power
well and to a large extent they inhibit
themselves from doing so because they
know that the intrinsics of these new
moons of power
are antithetical to their own nature
and so they kind of don't push the ball
as far as they could
so to the degree to which one chooses to
become competent
remember that that journey involved two
things reconnecting with meaningfulness
but also
becoming that kind of organism that was
most able to
explore this new landscape and become
adaptive to the real environment
to the degree to which you adopt that
you will in fact discover new forms of
potency and power that lay
ambient in the potential the new
environment that have not yet even
vaguely been discovered and you can
begin to leverage that
and we're sitting on the threshold of a
major transition well by by definition
that transition involves access to power
that dwarfs the power before it
so all the power that you may find
yourself facing and be a little bit
inhibited by
isn't actually the meaningful part the
meaningful part is what's the power that
lives beyond the far horizon
and can you become capable of actually
forming the kind of collective the kind
of group
a group of people who can who can trade
with each other
and connect with each other and
communicate with each other
avoiding a lot of the problems that we
were talking about earlier so we can
make it very practical
you just learn how to have real
conversations on twitter
it's possible it can happen try that as
just a basic rule
and the hypothesis is this one there's
three points here one is
you're no longer adding to the noise
that's like an ethical
first do no harm if you can just inhibit
yourself
from contributing evil to the world
that's a good thing
it's gonna take some work for me for
everybody it may involve the break
right just stop uh or or habits don't do
it while you're drunk
uh two uh you're you're also
in that in the in the act of doing that
avoiding harm to yourself
as you know like it's it's actually bad
for you to engage in that but three
much more importantly literally
everybody who you find is also
participating in that
every relationship that you can have
every communication that you can have
that actually is generative in the
context of twitter that is
building increasing competence of how to
do it
whether it's happening just in you or in
the relationship in the people you're
interacting with or in the context
of the larger story of people being able
to perceive it is building a new
kind of collaboration that is the
discovery the auto catalytic discovery
of what a decentralized collective
intelligence
that is driven by wisdom commons that's
a whole bunch of terms
actually looks like the new form of
governance that is simultaneously
most adaptive to the new environment but
also generates the most
positive use of that power without
killing everybody and there's a very
specific eye of the needle you can
thread
but the path that i'm describing the
methodology that i'm proposing
i believe is in fact the one that i
guess is there
individually and collectively but
that was absolutely outstanding and
hopefully
hopefully jordan we're going to be able
to get there thank you so much for
coming on the show
if people want to be able to find you
where is the best place to do that
online ironically enough
well uh youtube is where i've done most
of my stuff recently because i've found
that i've gotten
a little bit demoralized and lazy around
writing
for a period of about three years i
wrote a number of pieces on medium that
are still there
except for the one on q anon that they
censored um
and i i feel like i'm probably going to
begin writing again on sub stack just to
see how that feels
i promise i will never create a paywall
that's not the point
um but that's pretty much it i don't
really have other than that i don't
really have much of an online presence
john before we ask your last question
i'm just curious if you don't mind me
asking and if you're not happy to answer
it we'll just cut it out
what do you do day to day
um well a parent i have a two-year-old
so
i engage in parenting
[Laughter]
i spend time with my with my wife
i have a new practice that i really
enjoyed quite a bit as i
i have uh
there she is almost there
um i have a hot tub in my backyard
and i make myself an espresso or a
particular kind of beverage this
espresso based
uh and then actually sit in the hot tub
with my coffee and meditate
that sounds incredible you're nailing it
it's really good
it's amazing um and then it depends
right oftentimes i'll have one or two
conversations with people
some of whom i know some of whom are new
people um
often times i actually think about
things like this like i'd say probably
about three
three hours a day contemplating some
variation on this theme which is quite
complicated it's a lot of stuff
yeah recently i've actually been
focusing on uh
cryptocurrency in the blockchain because
it's uh
it's relevant now like sometimes it's
not and sometimes it is
and it's in a process right now of
gathering more
potential energy and so it will be
how do i say this right it's like it's
like a it's a part of the journey
it's definitely not the end but it's
part of it
and particularly the part where we shift
power from old structures to new
structures
yeah it is already it's going to be part
of the new structures that have a lot of
power
i expect that it will also go away in a
surprisingly rapid time but
in the order of like 10 to 20 years not
like two or three um
and so sensing that and being able to
navi uh like okay where are the trim
tabs that can have the most positive
influence
at the highest level and also different
levels would be an example of something
that i'll spend time on
when that kind of a what i call a kairos
or uh
an event that has lots of moment now
emerges
um well very interesting listen thanks
so much for coming on and as always we
have one final question for you
which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be um
i knew he would react like that yeah
that's a tricky one particularly given
how much we've just talked about
yeah well i i'm wondering and i don't
really know
but the thing that i would imagine or i
i suspect would be something like
a phrase that popped into my head a
while ago is pay more attention to the
ones you love
so the question that you may not be
talking about that you should be is
who do i love that i'm not paying enough
attention to
maybe that at the very least if you if
you ask that question it's probably a
very good one to ask
it is jordan hall thank you so much for
coming on uh all the links uh to
jordan's youtube channel and all that
good stuff will be in the description
thank you for watching uh yeah maybe
don't be so addicted to politics i don't
know
uh we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant interview about politics
7 p.m uk time they all go out uh take
care and see you soon
take care guys and get off twitter